Democratic congressman Adam Schiff was
the lead house manager during president
Trump's impeachment trial the
Intelligence Committee Chairman joins us
from Potomac Maryland congressman Schiff
it's really good to see you you're the
perfect person to talk to on this
particular day a lot of name-calling
going on in Washington certainly no love
lost between the two John Bolton calls
the president a liar the president calls
John Bolton a liar based on what you've
seen what you've read what concerns you
most that you see that you've seen in
this book when concerns me most in
addition to the fact of course that he
further demonstrates the quid pro quo
the president coercing Ukraine by
withholding this military assistance is
the fact that it was part of a pattern
of the president consistently putting
his personal political interests above
the interests of the nation and to the
detriment of our national security and
the president's just general unfitness
for office these were themes of course
that we emphasized during the trial
Bolton really confirms them I think
quite clearly in this book a lot of the
things that we're that we heard during
the trial or now we're also reading in
the book do you wish that the Democrats
would have pushed harder to have him
testify no Bolton made it clear that if
we subpoenaed him that he would sue us
and tie us up in court now this was even
after his deputies were willing to
testify they had the courage of their
convictions but Bolton's argument was
essentially no that it would potentially
impede on the on the president that
would violate potentially his
constitutional duty apparently those
concerns gave way to a 2 million-dollar
book offer the fact that he wasn't
willing to testify in the house and was
willing to tie us up in court for a long
time but willing to tell the story to a
book to make money for a book tells you
a lot about John Bolton's character
whether his testimony would have made a
significant difference in trial it may
have if it led to further evidence and
further witnesses but we'll never know
and this is the the price the country
had to pay for John Bolton's putting
profit above country well let's talk
about the book
the book because the Republicans say
he's a disgruntled employee with an axe
to grind who really is just simply
trying to sell a book do you think that
that makes you should we take the book
seriously I think we have to take the
book seriously because the allegations
in it are so consistent with other
evidence and and I so yes I think we do
need to because the portrait paints of
the president is one that we know to be
all too true somebody who puts his own a
personal interest above the national
interest that will be a continuing
danger to the country over the next
several months until the election so we
have to take it seriously you could
certainly question and I think should
question John Bolton's patriotism in
withholding this information during an
impeachment proceeding but that doesn't
necessarily detract from the seriousness
of what he alleges against the president
yeah what are the most stunning
allegations involved Chinese President
Xi that he says the president was
basically pleading with President Xi to
help him win the election in this
country when you hear that what do you
think well I have a couple strong
reactions to that part of the book the
first is of course this is a perfect
parallel to what he did with Ukraine
which was subjugate the the country's
interest to his own political fortunes
and try to get a foreign country to
illicitly help him in his campaign and
this appears to be what he was doing
with China as well and I think equally
disturbing was him telling President Xi
that he should go forward with these
concentration camps for the Uighur and
that it was the right thing to do that
is such a betrayal of everything our
country stands for such a betrayal on a
massive scale of our support for human
rights I don't know which is more
disturbing frankly but both prove his
unfitness for office as chairman of the
House Intelligence Committee will you do
anything now to investigate these these
new claims that we're hearing I'll be
discussing this with the speaker and
with my fellow chairs about what next
steps may be necessary we haven't had a
chance to read the book only excerpts
so I want to look deeply into the
allegations and have a chance to confer
about what the Congress should do about
what John Bolton has to say at this very
belated moment Bolton says that
Democrats committed in his words
impeachment malpractice because of only
focusing on the Ukraine part of the
inquiry does he have a point there would
you have handled it differently it's
stunningly disingenuous for John Bolton
to make that argument because what it
amounts to is the house should have
investigated things that I was unwilling
to tell them about well how are we going
to investigate it if he refused to
testify so you know Bolton only has
himself to blame if he thinks the house
should have looked into for example the
president's offered to try to dismiss a
case against the Turkish bank that was
evading Iranian US sanctions on Iran as
a way of pleasing a fellow autocrat or
so or another autocrat so no I think
John Bolton has to somehow rationalize
selling out by keeping this secret for
his book and that's the way he's
attempting to do it all right
congressman Schiff do you plan to read
the book I don't want to give him any
royalty or further income from the book
so I'll read the excerpts but I don't
intend to buy a copy all right thank you
very much for your time this morning sir